i don't think i've ever had one of these
oh it's going to be really bad
[Laughter]
oh my god
[Music]
hi i'm emily attack and this is snack
wars the uk versus the rest of the world
falad by rule
oh
so you've got your pork scratchings
and salted egg fish skin come on salted
egg fish skin they're not words that
should be in the same
sentence
the smell isn't too horrific
it's got coconut on there it's like a
hang on
it's growing on me
oh my god
it tastes like
it tastes a little bit like sweaty
bollocks
so sorry
and anyone that goes
don't know what sort of bollocks you've
had no come on like if you say it
doesn't taste like that you're lying
because it does i'm gonna go with the
salted egg fish skin because no one
likes a sweaty bollock
oh toxic waste from america and licorice
all sorts from the uk licorice is the
only flavor on this planet that i don't
like but i have a feeling i'm gonna like
that way more than this
i really don't like that flavor it's
like sambuca oh
it's exactly like
i'm in a bar
it's 3am it's it's you should be going
home but the sambucas have come out and
everyone's going come on just one you go
no no i can't oh man and you
accidentally have five
oh
horrible
i don't know why anyone would want that
in their mouth
this is going to hurt my mouth isn't it
i don't think i've ever had one of these
oh it's going to be really bad
come on
oh my god
oh my god no
oh my god
that
is absolutely horrific i don't want to
mummy take it away
i can't believe i'm going to say this
but these little licorice bastards
they win it for me pop you back in there
and never speak of you
ever again
this is an australian i believe a
4x gold
delicious
oh my god i want to go on holiday
vibes
i remember the day of standing around
in a bit with a beer and just lads
everywhere
all right let's do this one old speckled
hen this is uk isn't it yeah
mummy always tells me after doing that
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh love it i always find the names of
beers are really funny like old speckled
hen i'm a bit of an old speckled hen i'm
really freckly
and i run around like a mental hen
[Laughter]
i'm an old speckled head okay this is my
winner forex gold
crisps crisps are my favorite things in
the world oh never had these
okay
yeah lovely with a bit of hummus oh
gorgeous walkers
salt and vinegar
i love crisps these are the sort of
questions you have you know when like
you know
when it's gonna extend from the pub into
a big night out when someone me goes to
the bar knowing that no one's had any
tea so you get loads of crisps and then
you open the bags in the middle of the
table and never go you know it's going
to be
a 5 a.m joby but yeah i'm a bit bored of
them and you get hot
come on
become one of those people that opens
the bag and go oh my god there's no
christmas here i'm sorry like you get
half of a bag it's not even a full bag
my winner
is these
because i've never heard of them and i
love plantain and they were really
lovely sorry gary
and the winner is the rest of the world
good
yay
god i'm so cultured
picking up the walkers
i'm so cultured
[Music]
these
patties are really lovely when they just
come out the oven but down here at lad
bible they pop them into the microwave
it steams it all up
and it becomes a little bit floppy
but the taste
spicy